speaking of boneheads
trying to keep
things that people like out of their
hands you know people in pennsylvania
don't want to ban philly cheesesteaks
but
you know dr oz does he wants to put
vegetables only on your philly
cheesesteaks but here is
this woman from moms of liberty what a
name moms of liberty
of liberty almost like they don't even
know what the word liberty means
i forget her [ __ ] name here i don't
know her name but this is on this is on
she is she's she's mother liberty and
that's right no i'm sure i'm sure she is
um she's talking about peppa pig here
you know they freaked out when m ms they
changed how they drew a green eminem
remember that yeah yeah we're just going
to change it
when tucker
was like
you're gonna ruin our economy because
you're changing how you draw the green
eminem i mean they've changed yeah
again a private company decided to do
something with their own products right
right and then and then you have you
have the mr potato head remember they
freaked out about that because again
there's a word on the box right change
the word or the logo they change the
logo on the box the character is still
mr potato head but while there is a mrs
potato right
have a box looked but the name of the
group is just potato head right it's
just that's what it is there's no mister
on the brand there's a mr character they
never they never took away the [ __ ]
potato spuds dick okay guys right they
never did that do potatoes have dicks i
don't know i don't know i've you know
you've got one of those like you know
how they like grow roots and stuff yeah
maybe that's
a potato i don't know i don't know you
know you know who knows i don't know ted
cruz
they are obsessed with japanese they
probably wouldn't know sesame street
with it [ __ ] obsessed with that well
this [ __ ] mom of liberty this dis
[ __ ] she is [ __ ] completely obsessed
with what people do and what how i mean
i can't even imagine
how ted cruz and this lady is so
obsessed with cartoons like they are
obsessed with cartoons i'm like have you
have you went on the internet and
actually watched this anime porn stuff
you're not even you're not even skimming
there also where are you
pouring the iceberg here like if anyone
else is bringing it like republicans
will be like oh it's it's it's porn it's
anime porn it's cartoon it's
like this and it's like why are you
watching that other one right well you
know why are you
doing research like josh hawley well ted
cruz is obsessed with mickey [ __ ]
pluto like he can't stop talking about
how mickey [ __ ] pluto you would almost
think you well yeah i've seen him talk
about you know in his in his leather
reclining yeah as he's
so disconnected in his elitist form like
every three minutes he brings
this disney porn it's almost like the
way that ted cruz talks about these
other uh inanimate objects because they
are right they're either a cartoon that
is just two-dimensional
uh they are a a toy that is you know
it doesn't [ __ ] move unless you do it
right
you would think that the the talking
about are you talking about action
figures are you talking about something
else to other kind of toys well no any
other no any other toy oh okay
cruz does not want remember the whole he
tried to ban the dildos well i mean he
wants dillo's he just doesn't right he
wants them all for himself bro yeah yeah
yeah i mean
here's the thing
for as much as ted cruz talks about
these other inanimate
uh fiction characters right yeah
you would
you would kind of think that those were
the things that he's running against
like he's running for re-election in the
senate and [ __ ] goofy or mr potato
head
or [ __ ] peppa pig like any of these
people or any of these things were
running against him as a us senator for
texas that is the impression that i get
from ted cruz for the amount of time
that he spends so much that he thinks
he's running against mickey i mean
desantis thinks he's running against
mickey
yeah but you know let's listen to the
moms of
liberty lady here oh my god
you won't believe this [ __ ] when i
watched this this morning i was like
what in the [ __ ] are they talking about
they want they want to get rid of peppa
pig
because
there's two mommies in there i'm not
[ __ ] you this is the reason watch a
good portion of you know peppa pig is
out of great britain but it runs here in
america and a good portion of american
parents have deeply helped beliefs that
conflict with um the things that are
being put out in these cartoons for
toddlers
so change the channel dummy i was just
gonna say the [ __ ]
the great thing here
is it's your body
your choice
your tv okay you can choose whatever you
want to watch in your house if you don't
want to watch peppa pig don't turn it on
if you find that it's on some streaming
network don't pay for that streaming
network right i'm sure these companies
don't give a [ __ ] about what you pay for
and what you don't pay for so people
have tv freedom here in the united
states we got tv freedom your tv your
choice okay that's what i'm saying if
they don't want it on their tv
then don't [ __ ] play it but but the
act of them saying right now oh well
they've got a same-sex couple and it's a
british
show it's a british show but it airs
here in the us then don't go to that
channel the reason why it airs through
the network it's because it's really
[ __ ] popular because it's really
[ __ ] cute
if anyone out there has kids they know
our grandkids knows that this [ __ ]
show these kids love this [ __ ] show
and it's it if you think that this show
is bad
what the i watched looney tunes when i
was a [ __ ] kid and i'm gonna point
this out because i think this is
important listen to what she says and so
parents need to you know make the choice
and they need but they need to be
informed
yeah i i just want to be blunt about it
if there may be some viewers that watch
and say
is this being homophobic
yes yes you're about to be homophobic
uh some people might say that this is
transphobic homophobic racist ageist
ableist like if yeah that's what it is
something when you have this like thing
that precedes what you have where you're
like look some people might say this is
this
but and you're like dude you already by
the fact of you saying that
you've already taken away the ability to
claim that it's not that because you're
now using this as an excuse to be like
well look i'm not saying this it's other
people okay and if you're offended
that's on you right well which i mean
you have the right to be offended i also
have the right to know that you're about
to serve us up you're giving us the
warning hey
i'm about to be a homophobe yeah and
that's what they should just do is just
have like just flash in you're like
warning warning it's not warning to be a
homophobe alert you're we're about to
serve you the homophobic argument here
yeah and they're like make sure to tivo
this right and listen to this this is
that's incredible
but really what we're looking at or
rather what um
mom speaking out about this is looking
at is is it too young is it too soon to
introduce that am i analyzing that
correctly oh too young to introduce what
so you're telling me that a child
of a same-sex couple
should not acknowledge or learn about
what their parents are in the
relationship and how they fit within the
world at any point like they
these people
these people right now on the show are
going to say no that's inappropriate
people kids who are in uh or the the
child or children of a same-sex couple
guys it's too much for them to handle
they don't know how they they cannot
compute these things well here's the
thing is that what these people these
[ __ ] christian nationalists these
[ __ ] nazis are scared of what they're
terrified of is that the younger
generation sees that that someone has
two moms on on a cartoon which happens
in real life too yeah their children
have two moms two dads it happens some
have one mom some have one dad
it just and some have a mommy and a
daddy right that's what happens in
reality here kids right and what what
they're what they're terrified of
is that not that it's inappropriate it's
that that they won't be able to teach
their children bigotry that's what
they're scared of they're scared that
they won't be able to teach their
children to hate these people if peppa
pig shows them that it's yeah it's it's
no big deal right it's really nice and
god forbid that these shows which again
are popular in the u.s and you know
any you know what any show for that
matter that decides to discuss this do i
yeah no i don't watch it have you
uh i try to remember maybe if
it's cute as [ __ ] man yeah no i've seen
i've seen clips i'm just trying to
remember like if i was ever babysitting
you know in the past and watched it from
like a friend's kid or something it's
been on for a long time yeah like
millions of episodes so i mean like when
they sit down they can watch it for
years and not right right right you know
i'm sure i've passed kids with an ipad
in this in a in a restaurant too
watching peppa pig like on on the ipad
but i will say this like
not only just this show but the fact
that shows bring up you know
stories that are not just about a white
cis dude
it's a talking pig they're talking no no
i know i know but what i'm saying is
like you would you would almost think
like hey this company
this network who makes this show hey
says hey look our demographic our viewer
our like our actual
viewer base and the people who just are
representative in the world oh [ __ ]
they actually aren't just all white
straight people they're a person of
color they come from a different country
they have a different culture religion
they are in a different you know it's a
man and a man or woman a woman or you
know it's a non-binary person with
another nine bearing person or something
else right
like
it's not you're not grooming you're not
using this to create these things you're
not using the show to groom these people
these people exist and they were
represented yeah and they're represented
through the characters in the show right
so that when other people in society go
hey look
my family is different than their family
and now i can see a show where i can go
oh my god that relates because i can
tell you right now
children are very smart
they are very smarter than these two
[ __ ] bonuses oh yeah 100
they are able to pick on on things that
that most people don't there's no filter
and the under like the ability to
understand complex situations is
actually
it exists right that is something that
they get they can understand something
also as simple as this person loves this
person right and they are your parents
you need to know it's really no more
complex that's as far as your business
needs to go exactly but if you see that
if you see on here it says woke culture
because you know they've been on this
cancer culture for for [ __ ] years now
and the reason why they've been on this
tirade about cancer culture is because
they actually want to cancel things and
again it's all projection the imminent
thing the potato they're gonna cancel
themselves out of existence because
here's the thing they're gonna go down a
checklist and say we can't have this we
can't have that we can't have that we
can't have that and by the end of the
time they're confined within a box
that's like well you you you can't ever
go there and you can't ever say that you
can't do that because they were the ones
who are like
we are triggered
we are triggered by those things that
you
find
uh
uh to be a part of your lives which is
the woe culture right right woke oh
they're woke but listen it gets better
it gets better because we got to get the
bone in the week so let's let's let's
continue
yeah and parents need to know what their
kids are watching you know in the old
days you watched a cartoon there was
really nothing to discuss after it was
all kind of
non-political no agenda
you know just just funny things to laugh
at and you didn't really have to sit
down with your toddler afterwards or
your five-year-old and have a discussion
about what they just watched and so you
know if parents aren't ready to have
these conversations and this this here
is the image that they're that they're
terrified of
look at that they're sitting down and
they're eating pasta oh my god why are
we so triggered oh my god pigs shouldn't
eat pasta goddamn it they [ __ ] got
him a talking pig shouldn't eat pasta in
the kitchen and dress up apparently i've
never seen a pig with glasses but maybe
there are some also
also which i'm sure you're about to
bring up in a moment about like looney
tunes and things like that but like
there are cartoons dude i watched
[ __ ] running stimpy as a kid right
that [ __ ] was
that was not appropriate for a kid man
butthead is a buddha dude i'm not at all
dude these are jokes
on it for my bungle everybody no
even even even for ren and stimpy man
when they zoom in it is very graphic
right like they're like zoomed in on
like an eye that was like [ __ ] busted
and [ __ ] like that is not well i mean do
you remember the violence on on looney
tunes like all out violence do you
remember the racism or yeah well
do i and then the other thing too is
bugs bunny if you remember to get away
from elmer fudd would dress up and drag
to confuse elmer fudd because elmer fudd
apparently is a manga republican and he
would be confused do you also remember
you know pepper pew oh yeah they're
really
a little aggressive you know a little
rapey yeah
but here here they're scared of this
imagery here that comes out of britain
as they say let's let's continue with
their children then they need to not not
let them view these types of cartoons
and yeah
is that parents need to be aware because
they're just not they've they've watched
peppa pig i think it's been running for
20 years uh they've watched it forever
and they don't know this stuff is being
introduced so it's important that news
media outlets cover it and that people
speak out just so people are aware uh
they may choose to let their children
watch it and have the conversation or
they may not but it's their right to do
so wait wait yeah
you're telling me you're telling me that
a show is using its program to introduce
a topic that maybe should be discussed
at some point right hmm
maybe maybe you ran right into the point
there dummy let's let's continue he gets
he gets worse here watch this just a
snippet there um again it's two two moms
in the home no no it's two pigs yeah
they're pigs dude
they're female pigs they're two pigs and
and they're my mother pigs mommy pigs
yeah but they're not humans jesus christ
they're not real people it's a [ __ ]
two-dimensional cartoon right that's why
that's why people didn't drop anvils on
on other people's heads off a cliff
after they watched the roadrunner and
wiley coyote because it's a [ __ ]
cartoon
oh jesus
um
and many are asking is it too early i'm
just curious another night i've said you
so only you dumb fascists are asking um
obviously it may be in sprinkled into
other shows or other children's books as
we've covered on these broadcasts before
um
is there an is there an age appropriate
time for something like this these
cartoons obviously are are geared for
very young children can you imagine i'm
gonna stop there can you imagine if if
if these people were walking out in
public and they see
they see two people
with a young child
and they just they're like oh there's
two there's two women with one child and
they're eating spaghetti yeah at this
restaurant and they just freaked the
[ __ ] out i mean they're freaking out and
like hey wait a second i'm i'm this
child's mom and
she's
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i mean
really honestly that's what they're
doing here freak out
the woman so i just did a quick search
really quick the moms of liberty and i'm
reading about their about page was that
tiffany or was that tina i think it
might have been
tina tina okay so you know dina
deskovich right she has a long record of
fighting for students and parental
rights in florida at a national level
she was elected blah blah blah she was
elected again for this other thing while
on the board she was a member of the
florida coalition of school board
members and serves the organization
president 2018 tina currently serves on
several non-profits that's [ __ ]
terrifying in her community that are
aimed at helping children
nope not she and her husband derek
sounds like a dick have five children i
feel sorry for them if your mother is
this person who is that much of a
controlling uh fascist she's passionate
about american is dedicated to
protecting liberty and freedom
freedom
freedom now for the nature of all
children
so here's the thing i don't see anywhere
in this bio
that she's a clinical uh psychologist or
therapist
or uh um a pediatrician or anyone that
she's just a dumb maga republican is
that right you're saying like
i'm saying that she's not a trained
professional that would know the answer
to so at what point are we able to
introduce these things into a child's
life right that person on your own
personal level as a mother you can do
whatever you want right that's your
liberties that's your liberty and your
freedom and your own your own family
you have like joe biden says you have
the right to be a [ __ ] idiot yeah you
have the right to be an idiot
it's america speaking of rights to be
idiots i bet tina and this lady would
get along then we'll go to bonehead of
the week once yeah it's fun to be here
it's fun to have a big family who who
here has
who
who here has at least eight there's
eight kids in your family
[ __ ] beautiful kids
there's some breeders here
i'm not [ __ ] you let's back it up
let's rewatch before we go to bonehead
because this is a real [ __ ] bone in
here watch
this
yeah right there's a
there's some breeders here all right
little baby
oh my god tina and her would get along
really well oh that
is a bonus
wow jesus christ man breeders that type
of language is the same as like i need a
ve an earthen vessel
i need a i need a producer of of
bodies like there's there is there's a
great um part of liberty in this country
and joe biden said it so well you do
you do have the freedom and the right to
be really [ __ ] stupid and that
that is just
not the stupidest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard